companies have been blowing their cash
Reserves meta's reserves have declined
from 64 billion dollars to 37 billion a
decrease of 42 percent Google's reserves
have declined from 142 billion down to
115 billion a decrease of 19
Microsoft's reserves have declined from
136 billion down to 104 billion a
decrease of 23 and Apple's reserves have
declined from 107 billion down to 51
billion a decrease of 52 this isn't some
sort of a random fluctuation either for
the past decade all of these companies
have been vigorously increasing their
cash reserves up until the past 12 to 24
months with such massive decreases in
cash reserves you would think that these
companies have been furiously paying off
their debt but that's not the case
either Apple for example has maintained
their long-term debt at right around 100
billion Google and meta on the other
hand have even gone as far as increasing
their
Google has increased their long-term
debt by over 200 percent from 4 billion
to 14 billion meta on the other hand is
holding debt for virtually the first
time in the company's history this makes
no sense at all these companies were
hoarding cash into tens of billions if
not hundreds of billions when interest
rates were low so with high interest
rates you would think that they would
adjust the double down on their cash
reserves and pay off their debt as
quickly as possible but they've actually
been doing the exact opposite
so here's why companies are blowing
their cash reserves and where all this
money is going instead
starting off with the most obvious
reason we have high inflation during
times of high inflation idling cash is
rapidly losing its value so it makes
sense to decrease your cash reserves but
it's not actually that simple if you
look closer at these companies balance
sheets you'll see that many of them were
starting to slash their cash reserves
well before inflation got out of hand
inflation didn't even cross three
percent until the second recorder of
2021 but by this point Apple had already
decreased their cash reserves from 107
billion down to 61 billion
this trend is even more evident at
Microsoft who has refused to increase
their cash reserves since 2016 at this
point
during this same time period their net
income has rocketed from 25 billion per
year to 70 billion per year
so the choice to cap off their cash
reserves is very much an active one but
why well a lot of it can be explained by
Dr Michael Jensen's research paper that
was published way back in 1986.
the paper basically argues that holding
cash is a terrible sin for corporations
and the Jensen supports this idea with
five reasons we'll take a look at the
three most notable reasons the first
reason is that there is an inverse
correlation between cash reserves and
the organizational efficiency this makes
sense and you can probably relate to
this yourself when times are good you're
more likely to eat out more often by a
phone you don't need or keep
subscriptions that you don't even use
the same idea applies to companies the
more cash they have the more likely it
is that they overhire employees fund a
low Roi projects and pay uploaded
salaries
wait a minute isn't that the metaverse
anyway Jensen actually takes this idea
to the next level he not only argues
that higher cash reserves lead to lower
efficiency but higher debt levels
increase efficiency in other words
modest cash reserves and debt are
optimal for maintaining corporate
efficiency moving on to reason number
two this is more of an observation than
an argument Jensen observed that
leverage increasing transactions
correlate with a significant positive
increases in stock price while
leveraging decreasing transactions
correlate with significant decreases in
stock price the obvious reasoning for
this would be that companies taking on
debt are likely funding some sort of
expansionary effort while companies that
are reducing debt are likely taking risk
off the table moving on to number three
this is likely Jensen's most contentious
argument he basically argues that larger
cash reserves lead to more
diversification which is apparently bad
the idea is that companies are far more
likely to succeed when they invest in
areas that they're already dominant in
as opposed to a new area as cash
reserves grow however the temptation to
diversify into new businesses becomes
larger which often leads to more losses
than profits these conjectures have
simply been strengthened over the years
with the newer research one study for
example analyzed corporate earnings
growth between 1871 and 2001. the study
found that earnings grew the fastest
when corporate to dividend payout ratios
were the highest in other words when
companies were paying out most of their
profits conversely stock performance was
poor when companies hoarded cash none of
this is to say that cash reserves
themselves are leading to poor
performance but rather that uploaded
cash reserves are generally a sign of a
fundamental shift at a company a shift
that's usually not for the best
foreign
to be holding on to too much cash as a
corporation but then where do you put
all this money it's hard enough to
safely invest a few hundred thousand
dollars so how in the world you invest a
few hundred billion dollars well the
answer usually breaks down into three
main categories starting with short-term
Securities this primarily consists of
government bills that mature within the
next 12 months one-year government bills
are currently yielding 4.7 percent so
it's a pretty solid bet for corporations
not only are bills producing great
returns but they're also considered
risk-free as they're backed by the US
government in fact they're so safe that
bills are generally just counted as cash
remember how we talked about Apple
having 50 billion dollars in cash
reserves well only 20 billion of that is
actually Cash Cash the other 30 billion
is a marketable Securities or government
bills if we look even closer we'll see
that even the cash cash portion is not
fully cash the official title for this
entry is cash and cash equivalents this
basically means super short-term
government bills that are maturing
within the next month and or money
market funds so that's where companies
store the money that they needed within
the next 12 months or so as for longer
term reserves companies primarily turn
to government bonds once again but this
time the maturity is far longer
something like 10 to 15 years 10-year
government bonds or technically notes
are currently yielding 3.3 percent which
is much less than one-year bills but the
benefit is obviously that you get to
lock in this rate for a full 10 years
this is usually where companies store
the bulk of their cash Apple currently
has a whopping 114 billion dollars in
long-term marketable Securities so
basically all the cash goes to
government bonds of varying durations
but what if a company still has too much
money left well that's where the
infamous BuyBacks come into play buying
back stock allows for companies to
artificially inflate the value of their
stock due to simple supply and demand by
purchasing stock Apple is able to reduce
the amount of Apple stock that's
available on the market at the same time
there are also increasing the demand for
Apple stock because well they're buying
hundreds of billions worth in fact over
the past decade Apple has bought back
wait for it
573 billion dollars worth of stock
perspective that's enough money to buy
out the ninth largest company in the
world cash apple is not alone in this
trend either Google has spent 150
billion within the past five years
Facebook has spent 100 billion within
the past five years Microsoft has spent
170 billion within the past 10 years and
the corporations as a whole have spent a
5.3 trillion dollars on stock BuyBacks
within the past 10 years so invest in
cash into government securities and
stock BuyBacks hasn't very much been the
go-to strategy for corporations
historically but this has started to
change in recent times
thank you
as you can see here large cash reserves
are usually a dark sign for corporations
so they try to make sure that cash
reserves don't get too out of hand by
investing in government securities and
stock BuyBacks but that's the old school
method the new school method is to trade
cash for something much more valuable
the reality is that the value of cash is
declining and I don't mean because of
inflation I mean that the fundamental
value of cash as a currency itself is
declining this isn't a new trend by any
means either cash has been a sub-optimal
currency for over a hundred years at
this point basically since the Fed was
created way back in 1913. since then
it's been ingrained in our minds that
currencies lose a value over time
because that's all we've ever seen with
cash but this isn't not true good
currencies increase in value and for a
very long time cash was actually a great
currency in fact between 1800 and 1900
the value of cash actually increased 1.
1800 was only worth 67 cents in 1900.
think about that money in 1900 was worth
more than it was a hundred years before
that of course this changed with the FED
but that's not to say that all
currencies became inflationary the new
currency to hold was gold at least until
FDR banned it in 1933 following the ban
the new currency to hold was oil all of
the richest people in the world between
the 1930s and 1970s were those who
controlled oil with the 1980s and
Reaganomics however the optimal currency
switched to being stuck and that's how
it's been since then billionaires like
Jeff Bezos Elon Musk and the Bill Gates
aren't holding oil gold or cash they're
holding stock but this is once again
changing the new currency is attention
and the biggest companies in the world
that know this more than anyone this is
why they're more than happy to pay
ridiculous sums of money to buy
attention likely the best example of
this is WhatsApp when they were acquired
they were completely worthless from a
traditional business perspective despite
having 450 million users the app was
only bringing in 10.2 million dollars in
revenue and was losing 138 million
dollars
another way to look at this is that each
user was bringing in a glorious 2.3
cents per year and losing the company 30
cents obviously a terrible situation
from a financial perspective Facebook
could have easily gone out and
replicated the app for no more than 10
million dollars and even that's being
generous but what Facebook could not
replicate was the interest that WhatsApp
had and that's why they pay their
ludicrous 99 billion dollars for the
company or 42 dollars per user this is
the same reason that Microsoft bought
Skype for 8.5 billion why Apple bought
beats for 3 billion when Microsoft
bought GitHub for seven and a half
billion why Microsoft bought LinkedIn
for 26 billion by Salesforce bought
slack for 27 billion and why Elon bought
Twitter for 44 billion dollars none of
these companies created something truly
revolutionary more times than not their
products could be replicated for a few
hundred thousand dollars or a few
million dollars Max but what's nearly
impossible to replicate is their user
base and that's why Tech Giants are
blowing all their cash requiring these
startups essentially they're trading
their cash and or stock for attention as
that's the far more valuable currency
for most people being financially rich
is defined by having a bunch of cash but
for most companies this is a nightmare
growing cash reserves indicate that
you're running out of places to invest
and to grow the company which is a big
No-No for investors traditionally
companies would trade their cash for
Bonds in stock as these were the
superior currencies and these are still
very popular options today
but more and more we're starting to see
companies trade cash for attention
they're not looking for cash flow or
solid business fundamentals or a unique
business or any of that what they're
looking for is how to maximize the
attention that they can get for their
cash as this is the real currency of the
21st century currently there are still a
bunch of companies in the Fortune 500
that aren't doing this but give it 20 30
40 years and the only way to be in the
Fortune 500 will be to control attention
and that's why the smartest companies
are blowing their cash reserves in
return for attention
would you rather have cash or attention
comment that down below also drop a like
if you'd like to see more economical
analyzes just like this one and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community such as for the video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign